apparently witch-hunt and presidential
harassment are no longer good enough
phrases for Donald Trump to describe a
legal constitutionally enshrined process
called
an impeachment inquiry so Donald Trump
is switching to racialized language now
calling the impeachment inquiry a
lynching this happened in yet another
completely unhinged uncontrolled
unfettered Twitter rant check it out in
its full glory Donald Trump tweeting
quote so someday if a Democrat becomes
president and the Republicans win the
house even by a tiny margin they can
impeach the president without due
process or fairness or any legal rights
all Republicans must remember what they
are witnessing here a lynching but we
will win some kind of white billionaire
lynching I guess is what we are a scene
here also just referred to as the proper
consequences to the actions of Donald
Trump so there's a lot of stuff here I
mean every element of this tweet is very
dumb the lynching pieces maybe the most
absurd but let's go through it one by
one I mean Trump sense says there's no
due process if anyone is interfering
with due process it's Donald Trump and
the people working for Trump who are
ignoring legal congressional subpoenas
yesterday I told you about eight
congressional subpoenas that are overdue
and that there may be no consequences
for that's interfering with due process
but more importantly and this is a
really important thing to understand the
due process piece comes if and when the
House of Representatives decides to
actually argue for the impeachment and
removal of Donald Trump and there will
be due process the house of
representatives will make that case and
ultimately the Senate will vote as to
whether to convict Donald Trump on
impeachment on the allegations contained
within the eventual impeachment articles
that is due process this is just an
inquiry okay and I saw there was
actually I forget who it was but there
was a reporter on CNN in the last 24
hours
who did it might've been John Berman who
did a good job of not letting whoever
the Trump official was play games with
this because
due process is not an issue right now it
is merely an inquiry at this point in
time due process will apply if and when
impeachment is carried on and the Senate
gets to vote so Trump saying there's no
due process that's not true he's the one
interfering with due process now the
question of fairness that Trump brings
up is sort of a laughable one but if we
want to talk about fairness in a fair
world in a properly functioning world
Donald Trump would have been removed
from office a while ago for his endless
violations of the emoluments clause and
money laundering putting aside all other
issues in terms of legal rights I don't
even know what Trump is talking about
impeachment is something that the house
has always had the power to do
Republicans threatened Obama with
impeachment they knew Obama didn't
actually do anything to justify
impeachment and then in comes Trump
brown-noser Lindsey Graham after Trump
uses the word lynching the Republican
senator from South Carolina and he also
says that it's a lynching albeit a
political one saying it's a political
lynching in every sense so I actually
think it's not that useful to focus on
Trump's use of this racialized word
lynching and there's a couple reasons
why one is if Trump is deliberately
trying to trigger the left by using a
racialized term lynching of course
referring to the hanging of black
Americans at different points in the
history of the United States if Trump is
deliberately trying to trigger the left
it's not useful to take the bait if
Trump is using the term metaphorically
or whatever although Donald Trump has
not shown any evidence that he can think
metaphorically it's also important not
to go crazy around the term because yeah
I mean listen Trump being racially
insensitive is not a new thing but as
soon as the lynching term started
becoming the topic of discussion people
pointed out that Joe Biden use the
phrase also in a non-literal context
during the 90s and then Joe Biden had to
come out and say well listen the
difference is I recognize that that was
the wrong word to use and I no longer
use it but you're immediately sort of
muddying up the waters it's important to
understand that the real issue here is
Trump believes he's above the
Trump again being racially insensitive
is not fundamental to thinking about
what should happen next to Donald Trump
as president of the United States
realizing that not only does Trump think
he's above the law but that in effect he
is unless Democrats actually do
something about enforcing congressional
subpoenas etc that is actually the most
important thing here Cory Booker is
pointing out on Twitter that lynching is
an act of terror used to uphold white
supremacy and of course Cory Booker is
not wrong all of the comments I've seen
about the use of the term lynching are
essentially correct but this is Donald
Trump and these are trumpets that we're
dealing with and there is little to gain
from going crazy over Trump's yet again
another use of racially insensitive
terminology we are much better off
enforcing that this is not a lynching it
is not a witch-hunt it is nothing other
than a legal constitutionally enshrined
process for attempting to hold the
president accountable which Donald Trump
and the people around him are ignoring
and they may well get away with ignoring
unless Democrats do something about it
that's my position on this
we don't minimize Trump's insensitive
use of the term lynching but we focus on
the fact that it is no call it whatever
you want lynching witch-hunt whatever
but Donald Trump is going to get away
with all of it unless Democrats actually
start enforcing their constitutionally
enshrined powers to investigate the
misdeeds of the President of the United
States now if you disagree with me I
want to hear from you if you believe
that actually the focus should be not on
Trump flouting the law but on Trump's
use of the term lynching which I concede
is disgusting then let me know why
strategically that makes sense leave a
reply for watching on YouTube send me a
tweet at D Pakman or follow me on
Instagram we will have a post there
about this at David Pakman I will speak
to you then and much more about the
latest days news right after this short
break the David Pakman show is possible
thanks to sponsors like VIN Charo
watchers giving
everyone in our audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch I just got a
couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether in silver and white and what
I love about this one
number one the Roman numeral at the top
of the face the white face is great this
is a chronograph model and I love the
blue leather band it's just a really
nice looking watch everybody who sees me
wear this one always asks about it what
I like about Vince arrow as a watch
brand is you're getting quality and
you're getting a watch where it's clear
as soon as you open the box that a lot
of care and artisanship went into the
design and the way that the watch is put
together I'm not interested in paying
thousands of dollars for a watch when I
can get one that's reasonably priced and
looks just as nice and has terrific
build quality and that's exactly what
Vince arrow is in the business of doing
putting a ton of craftsmanship into
their watches making them available for
a hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
you really can't go wrong check them out
at david pakman.com slash watch support
the people who support our show and
you'll save fifteen percent when you use
that link